the thing about research is you never
know when those breakthroughs are gonna
come through you know so when we started
this project last year we thought it
would take a couple of years but you
know we made faster progress than we
expected and then sometime last month we
were like looks like we're there we
should just publish that's what we did
you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using humans are
wired to communicate but we don't always
understand each other
especially when we don't speak the same
language but a rule manassas the partner
research manager who heads MSRs machine
translation team is working to remove
language barriers to help people
communicate better and with the help of
some innovative machine learning
techniques and the combined brainpower
of machine translation natural language
and machine learning teams in redmond in
beijing it's happening sooner than
anyone expected today a rule mayonnaises
talks about how the advent of deep
learning has enabled exciting advances
in machine translation including
applications for people with
disabilities and gives us an insight
look at the recent human parity
milestone at Microsoft Research where
machines translated a news dataset from
Chinese to English with the same
accuracy and quality as a person that
and much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
a Ruhlman asus welcome to the podcast
today thank you I'm delighted to be here
so you're a partner research manager at
Microsoft Research and you had the
machine translation team which if I'm
not wrong falls under the umbrella of
human language technologies yes what
gets you up in the morning what's the
big goal of your team
well translation is just a fascinating
problem right I've been working in it
for almost two decades now and it never
gets old because there's always
something interesting or unusual or
unique about getting the translations
right the nice thing is that we've been
getting steadily better over the last
few years so it's not a solved problem
but we're making great progress so it's
sort of like a perfect problem to work
on so it's enough to get you out of bed
and you know keep you going yeah because
you're not so hard that you give up and
it's not solved yet
Monica's perfect bed yeah so your team
has just made a major breakthrough in
machine translation and we'll get into
the technical ways about how you did it
in a bit but for now tell us what you
achieved and why it's noteworthy so the
result we showed was that our latest
research system is essentially at parity
with professional human translators and
the way we showed that is that we got a
public test set that's generally used in
the research community of Chinese
English news we had it translated by
professional translators and we also had
it translated by our latest research
systems and then we gave it to some
evaluators who are bilingual speakers
and of course this is a blind test so
they couldn't tell which was which and
at the end of the evaluation our system
and the humans scored essentially the
same so you know the result is that for
the first time really we have a credible
result that says that humans and
machines are at parity for machine
translation now of course keep in mind
this is a very specific domain this is
news and it's one language pair
so you know we don't want to sort of
oversell it but it is exciting what
about the timing of it you had had plans
to do this but did it come when you
expected the thing about research is you
never know when those breakthroughs are
gonna come through you know so when we
started this project last year we
thought it would take a couple of years
but you know we made faster progress
than we expected and then sometime last
month we were like looks like we're
there we should just publish and that's
what we did is this sort of like a
touring test for machine translation
which one did it a computer or a human
in a limited sense we didn't ask people
to actually detect which was the human
and which was the machine because there
may be little tells like you know maybe
there's a certain capitalization pattern
or whatever what we did was we had
people just score the translation on a
scale like a just a slider early and
tell us how good the translation was so
it was a very simple set of instructions
that the evaluators God and the reason
we do that is so that we can get very
consistent results and people can
understand the instructions and so you
score the translations send us by
sentence and then you take the averages
across the different humans and the
machine and turned out basically were
the same score why did you choose
Chinese English translation first so we
wanted to pick up publicly use test set
because you know we're trying to engage
with the research community here and we
wanted to have a test set that other
people have worked on that we could
release all of our findings and results
and evaluations there's an annual
workshop in machine translation that's
been going on for the last ten or more
years called the WMT and so we use the
same methodology that they use for
evaluation and we also wanted to use the
same test set and they recently added
Chinese they used to be focused more on
European languages but they added
Chinese and so we thought that would be
a good one to tackle especially because
it's an important language pair and you
know it's hard but not too hard
obviously at least as it turned out
you've had another very impressive
announcement recently just this month
even that impacts what I can do with
machine translation on my phone
and I'm all yours what is it and why is
it different from other machine
translation apps yes it was super
excited about that because you know
we've had a translator app for Android
and Apple phones for a while and one of
the common use cases is of course when
people are travelling and the number one
request we get from users is can I do
translation on my phone even though I'm
not connected because when I'm traveling
I don't always have a data plan I'm not
always connected with Wi-Fi at the point
when I'm trying to communicate with
someone like a taxi driver or waiter or
a reception in the hotel and so we had
we've had for a while what we call an
offline pack you can download this pack
before you travel and then once you have
that you can do translations on your
phone without being connected to the
cloud but the thing about these packs is
that they've haven't been using the
latest neural net technology because
neural nets are very expensive take a
lot of computation and no one's been
able to really run a neural machine
translation on a phone before and so
last year we started working with our
major for manufacture and they had a
phone that had a special neural chip and
we thought it'd be super exciting to run
neuro translation offline on the phone
using this chip and so this month we
have been working to improve the
efficiency do a lot of careful
engineering and we managed to get it
working on any phone without relying on
the special hardware so what we released
this month was that anyone who has an
Android or iPhone can download these
packs and then they'll have neuro
translation on their phone so that means
even if they're not connected to the
cloud they're going to get really fluent
translations so it's the latest
cutting-edge translation technology yeah
right on your phone yeah super exciting
I wish I had that last summer to
actually yeah it's you know it's a very
useful app when you travel yeah is it
unique to Microsoft research and
Microsoft in general or yeah as far as I
know nobody else has neuro translation
running on the phone now this is only
text translation we don't yet have the
speech recognition are you working on
that oh we are we don't really have a
date for that yet but something that
we're interested in I'll postpone my
next trips
got it done let's get specific about the
technology behind ms ARS research in
machine translation you told me that
neural network architectures are the
foundation for the AI training systems
but your team used some additional
training methods to help boost your
efforts to achieve human parity in
Chinese English news translation so let
me ask you about each one in turn and
let's start with a round-trip
translation technique called dual
learning what is it how did it help
right so one of the techniques we used
to improve the quality of our research
system that reached the human parity was
what we called e-learning the way you
train a regular machine translation
system is typically with parallel data
so these are previously translated
documents in say Chinese and English
that are aligned at the sentence level
and then the neural net model
essentially learns to translate the
sentence from Chinese into English and
that's the signal that we use to train
the models now you can do the same thing
in the opposite direction in English
Chinese so what we do with dual learning
is now we couple those two systems and
we train them jointly so you use the
signal from the English to Chinese
translation to improve the Chinese to
English and vice versa so it literally
is very much like what a human would do
where you'd might do a round-trip
translation where you translate from
English to Chinese but you're not sure
if it's good so you translate back into
English and see how it went and if you
get it consistent you have some faith
that translation may be good and so this
is what we did so it's basically a joint
loss function for the two systems and
then there's another thing you can do
when you have this dual learning working
which is that in addition to the
parallel data you can also use
monolingual data let's say you have
Chinese texts you can send it through
the Chinese English system and then the
English to Chinese system and then
compare the results and that's a signal
you can use to train both systems so
another technique you used is called
deliberation Network
what is that and how does that add to
the translation accuracy right so the
other thing that our team did and I
should say that both the dual learning
and the deliberation Network work was
actually done by our partners in
Microsoft Research Asia the effort was a
joint effort of my team here in Redmond
which is the machine translation team
and the two teams in Microsoft Research
Beijing the natural language group and
the machine learning team then both the
dual learning and the deliberation
Network came out of the machine learning
team in MSR Beijing the way deliberation
networks work is essentially it's a two
paths translation process so you can
think about it as creating a rough
translation and then refining it and you
know human might do the same thing as
where you essentially create a first
draft and then you edit it so the
architecture of the deliberation network
is that you have a first pass neural
network encoder decoder that produces
the first translation then you have a
second pass which takes both the
original input in Chinese as well as the
first pass output and it takes both of
those as inputs in parallel and then
produces a translation by looking over
both the original input as well as the
first pass in what it's essentially
learning let's say which parts of the
first pass translation to copy over say
and which parts maybe need to be changed
and the parts that it change it would
decide to look at the original so the
output of the second pass is our final
translation I mean in theory you could
keep doing this because you know we just
do two passes and that seems to be
enough yeah that I was actually gonna
ask that it's like how many passes is
enough before you kind of I would
imagine that after like two passes
you're likely to converge so the third
tool that we talked about is called
joint training or left-to-right
right-to-left consistency explain that
and how it ments the system yeah so
again this is a work from the natural
language group in MSR Beijing they
noticed that if you produce a
translation output one word at a time
from left to right or in a different
system that produces the translation
again one word at a time but from right
to left you actually get different
translations and the idea was if you
could make these true translations
consistent you might get better
translation and the reason is if you
think about in many languages when you
produce a sentence there's later parts
of the sentence that need to be
consistent say grammatically or in terms
of gender or number or pronoun with
something earlier in the sentence but
sometimes you need something early in
the sentence to be consistent with
something later in the sentence but you
haven't produced that yet so you don't
know what to produce whereas if you did
it right to left you would be able to
get that right so by forcing the left
right system and the right to left
system to be consistent with each other
we could improve the quality of the
translation and again this is a very
similar iterative process to what we're
talking about with dual learning except
that instead of the consistency being
Chinese English English Chinese it's
left to right and right to left so what
was the fourth technique that you added
to the mix to get this human parody in
the Chinese to English translation yes
so we also did what's called system
combination so we trained a number of
different systems with different
techniques with variations on different
techniques with different
initializations and then we took our
best six systems and did a combination
in our case it was what's called a
sentence level combination so it really
is just picking off the six which one is
the best so essentially each of the six
systems producing and best lists like
say they're ten best candidates for
translation so now you've got 60
translations and you rescore them and
pick the best people have done system
combination of the word level before
where you take part of a translation
from one and part of a translation from
the other but that doesn't work very
well with needle translation because you
can really destroy the fluency of the
sentence by just sort of cutting and
pasting it's in pieces from here and
there yeah yeah we've seen that done
without machines yeah it gets butchered
in translation
[Music]
most of us have fairly general machine
translation needs but your researchers
addressed some of the needs in a very
domain-specific arena in the form of
presentation translator can you tell us
more about that
right so a present tension translators
this unique add-in that we have
developed for PowerPoint where when you
are giving a presentation you just click
the button and you can get transcripts
off your lecture displayed on screen so
that people in the audience can follow
along in addition the transcripts are
made available to audience members on
their own forum so they use our app and
just you know enter a code and then they
can connect to the same transcription
feed and they can get it either in the
language of the speaker or in their own
language and so essentially with this
one add-in we're addressing two real
needs one is for people who are deaf or
hard of hearing where the transcript can
help them follow along with what's going
on in the classroom or in a lecture and
also language learners foreign students
who can follow along in their own
language if they are not that familiar
with the language of the speaker and so
we've had a lot of excitement about this
in the educational field with both
school districts as well as colleges and
in particular the Rochester Institute of
Technology which has one of the colleges
in the university is called the National
Technical Institute for the deaf and so
they have a very large student body of
deaf students and so they have been
providing sign language interpretation
this gave them an opportunity to expand
the coverage Sligh providing this
transcription in the classroom so is it
from text to text on the PowerPoint
presentation so it's the user speaker
yeah so the professor is lecturing and
everything that they say is transcribed
both on screen and on people's for o my
gosh and then because it's on their
phone they can also save the transcript
and then that becomes class notes
and the other thing that's really cool
about presentation translator is that it
uses the content of your PowerPoint this
is why it's connected to PowerPoint it
uses the content of your slides to
customize the speech recognition system
so that you can actually use the
specialized terminology off the class
and it will be recognized so you know if
someone's teaching a biology class it'll
recognize things like mitochondria or I
was so which in other contexts would not
be recognized so you told me about how
you can use this with the
domain-specific or business specific
needs as well right about that one of
the things we're super excited about is
that we have the ability to customize
our machine translation system for the
domain and the terminology of specific
companies we have a lot of customers who
use translation to translate their
documentation their internal
communications product listings and the
way to get really high quality
translation for all of these scenarios
is to customize the translation to the
terminology that's being used by that
business part of the challenge of
machine translation is that human
language can't be reduced to ones and
zeros
it's got nuance it's got ins richness
and fluidity and so there are detractors
that start to criticize how
unsophisticated machine translation is
but you said that they're missing the
point sort of of what the goal is yeah
talk about that a little bit and how
should we manage our expectations conroy
machine translation yeah so I mean the
kind of scenarios that were focused on
with machine translation today have to
do with sort of everyday needs that
people have whether you're a traveler or
you maybe want to read a website or a
news article or a newspaper or you're a
company when you're communicating with
customers who speak a different language
or you're communicating between
different branches of the enterprise
that speak different languages most of
the language that is being translated
today it's pretty prosaic I mean it's
not that hard
well it is hard but we've gotten to the
point where we can do a pretty good job
of translating that
kind of text of course you know if you
start getting into fiction and poetry it
is very hard and we're nowhere obviously
with that kind but that's not that's not
our goal at this point so how would you
define your goal I think the goal for
translation today is to make the
language barrier disappear for people in
everyday contexts you know at work when
they're traveling so that they can
communicate without a language barrier
right so that kind of leads into the
idea that every language has its own
formal grammar and semantics and it also
has local patois yeah as it were and it
often leads to humorous missed
translations so how our machine learning
researchers tackling that lost in
translation problem so machines don't
end up making that classic videogame
mistranslation all your base are belong
to us there's two things I mean with
better techniques we have gotten a lot
better at producing fluent translations
so we would not produce something like
that today but it is still the case that
we're very dependent on the data we have
available so in the languages where we
have sufficient data we can do a really
good job when you get to languages where
there's not that much data or you get to
you know dialects or variations of
language where there's not that much
data it becomes a lot tougher and I
think this is something machine
translation shares with all a eye and
machine learning fields is that you know
we're very dependent on the data there
are ways to get iteratively better by
continually learning based on how people
use your product right how much are you
dealing interdisciplinarily with other
fields you are computer scientists right
and your data is language which is human
and expressive and all they're all over
the world yeah who do you bring in to
help you so we have linguists on our
team that you know make sure that we're
translating things correctly so for
example one of the linguists on our team
looks for things that are
Metrix don't catch so you know every
time we produce a new version of our
translation system we have various
scoring functions the one that we use
which is a very popular metric is called
blur and so that gives you a single
number that says how well is your system
doing so you know in principle if the
version of your system this month is you
know slightly better blue schoo than the
version last month they're like great
it's better you know ship it but then
what Lee who's the linguist or my team
does is she looks at it and tries to
spot things that may not be caught by
that score so for example how are we
doing with names how are we doing with
capitalization how are we doing with
dates and times and numbers there's a
lot of phenomenon that are very
noticeable to humans that are not
necessarily picked up by the automatic
metric
[Music]
let's talk about you for a second how
did you end up doing machine translation
research at Microsoft Research yes I was
in a ph.d program in sort of the
system's area in the computer science
department Stanford and I spent a couple
of summers up here and at the end of my
second summer I decided I wanted to stay
and so I did I just never went back and
I worked on a number of products at
Microsoft but at some point I wanted to
get back into research and so I moved to
Microsoft research and I started the
translation project actually in about
the year 2000 so basically the year my
daughter was born and now she's going
off to college and you've watched her
language grow over the years it's
actually when you're studying language
listening to how kids learn language is
fascinating it's just wonderful there's
a spectrum here and Microsoft of you
know pure research to applied research
stuff that ends up in products and you
seem to straddle what your work is about
being in products but also in the
research phase yeah one of the things
that's super exciting about our team is
that and it makes us somewhat unique I
think is we have everything from the
basic research and translation to the
web service that serves up the api's the
you know the cloud service that people
call to the apps that we have on the
phone so we have everything from you
know the things that users are directly
using down to the basic research it's
all in one team so you know when
somebody comes up with something cool we
can get it out to users very quickly and
that's very exciting I always ask my
podcast guests my version of the what
could possibly go wrong question which
is is there anything about your work in
machine translation that keeps you up at
night well so we always have this
challenge that we are learning from the
data and the data is sometimes
misleading and so we have things that we
do to try and clean up the data we do
have a mechanism for example to be able
to respond to those kinds of issues
quickly and it has happened we've had
situations where somebody discovered
translation that we produce that was
offensive and posted on Twitter and you
know it kind of went viral and some
people were upset about it and so we had
to respond quickly and fix it and so we
have people who are on call 24 hours a
day to fix any issue that arises like
that so it's the thing that literally
does keep somebody up at night
definitely at least during the night
shift version of it as we wrap up our
rule what advice would you give to
aspiring researchers that might be
interested in working in human language
technologies and why would someone want
to come to Microsoft research to work on
those problems so I think we live in an
absolutely fascinating time right like
people have been working on AI for hold
machine translation for that matter for
50 60 years and for decades there was a
real struggle and I would say just in
the last 10 years with the advent of
deep learning were making amazing
progress towards these really really
hard tasks that people at some point had
almost given up hope you know that we
would ever be successful at recognizing
speech or translating anywhere close to
the level that a human can but here we
are it's a super exciting time what's
even more exciting is not only have you
made tremendous progress on the research
side but now all of those techniques are
being put into products and they're
impacting people on a daily basis and I
think Microsoft's an amazing place to be
doing this because we have such a
breadth you know we have a range of
products that go all the way from
individual users in their homes to
multinational companies and so we have
just so many places that power
technology can be used in the range of
opportunity you have at Microsoft I
think is incredible a real Meneses thank
you for taking time to come up and talk
to us today it's been really interesting
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
to learn more about our role manassas
and the exciting advances in machine
translation visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]